SEES.
THEY TRY TO CHANGE THE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF YOUR
COUNTRY.
THAT WORKS.
IF WASHINGTON FINALLY
DECIDES TO FIX THE COUNTRY'S
IMMIGRATION PROBLEM, MARK
MORGAN WILL BE AT THE VERY
HEART OF THAT YOU KNOW HIM
FROM THIS SHOW.
HE HAS BEEN A FREQUENT
GUEST.
HAPPY TO HAVE HIM EVERY TIME
HE HAS BEEN ON.
THE PRESIDENT'S NEW PICK TO
RUN ICE.
FIRST INTERVIEW SINCE
STARTING THE JOB.
MORGAN, THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: THANKS FOR
JOINING US.
WHAT ARE YOUR PRIORITIES?
>> FIRST AND FOREMOST, I
THINK ANYONE IN THIS
POSITION IS A-TO-MAKE SURE
THAT I'M GOING TO BE A
RELENTLESS ADVOCATE FOR THE
MEN AND WOMEN OF ICE FOR THE
TOOLS NECESSARY TO DO THEIR
JOB.
PART OF WHAT THAT MEANS ALSO
IS GETTING OUT HERE, DOING
WHAT I'M DOING RIGHT NOW TO
EDUCATE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
EXACTLY WHAT THE HARD
WORKING MEN AND WOMEN OF ICE
DO EVERY DAY TO SAFEGUARD
THE SECURITY OF THIS COUNTRY
AND ENFORCE THE RULE OF LAW.
AND ALSO WORKING WITH
CONGRESS.
HERE IS THE PROBLEM WITH
THAT TUCKER.
CONGRESS HAS SHOWN INABILITY
TO DO WHAT THEY KNOW THEY
NEED TO DO TO FIX THIS
CRISIS.
I HAVE BEEN ON HERE MANY
TIMES SAYING THEY NEED TO DO
SEVERAL THINGS IN THE LEGAL
FRAMEWORK THEY CAN FIX THIS
IN 15 MINUTES.
ALTHOUGH I'M GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK TIRELESSLY
WITH CONGRESS TO TRY TO GET
THEM TO DO THEIR JOB, I
DON'T HAVE HOPE THAT THEY
ARE GOING TO, WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO COME UP WITH
INNOVATIVE IDEAS WITHIN THE
LEGAL FRAMEWORK WHERE WE CAN
TO STOP THIS PROBLEM.
>> Tucker: THEY HAVE
COMPLETELY POLITICIZED YOUR
AGENCY COMPLETELY.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Tucker: MOVING INTO THE
HEAT OF AN ELECTION SEASON.
A NUMBER OF THE CANDIDATES
HAVE CALLED FOR GETTING RID
OF ICE COMPLETELY.
HAVE COMPARED YOU TO THE
NAZIS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Tucker: REALLY OVER THE
TOP STUFF.
GIVEN YOUR EXPECTATION THEY
ARE NOT GOING TO HELP AT
ALL.
WHAT CAN THEY DO.
>> GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE.
ICE HAS THREE MAJOR
COMPONENTS.
CONGRESS DON'T EACH REALIZE.
THEY HAVE THE ENFORCEMENT
REMOVAL OPERATIONS.
DEPORTS PEOPLE.
THEY ALSO HAVE AN INCREDIBLE
TEAM OF LAWYERS THAT'S
INTEGRAL PART OF THE OVERALL
IMMIGRATION PROCESS THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY NEEDED.
AND THEN THE LAST PART OF
ICE IS HHI.
HOMELAND SECURITY
INVESTIGATIONS.
I WILL GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE.
THOSE THREE MAJOR COMPONENTS
MAKE UP ICE.
HSI FOR EXAMPLE WHAT WE HAVE
DONE IS TAKEN 150, HIGHLY
TRAINED, EXPERIENCED HSI
AGENTS AND WE PUSHED THEM
TOWARDS THE BORDER.
AND WHAT THEY ARE DOING IS
THEY ARE LOOKING AT CHILD
EXPLOITATION.
THEY ARE LOOKING AT THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
GRABBING, RENTING A KID,
RIGHT, AND WE CALLED, THIS
TUCKER.
WE KNEW THIS WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
AND IT IS.
THEY ARE RENTING KIDS, THEY
ARE PAYING TO RENTS
SOMEBODY'S KID AND THEN TAKE
THEMSELVES AS A FAMILY.
RIGHT NOW INFUSED THE D.N.A.
TESTING THAT WE TALKED ABOUT
IN THE PAST.
SO BETWEEN THE INVESTIGATIVE
SKILLS AND D.N.A. TESTING
RIGHT NOW THE PILOT PROGRAM
THEY ARE FINDING 25% OF
SO-CALLED FAMILIES COMING
ACROSS ABSOLUTELY FAKE,
FRAUDULENT.
JUST THE OTHER DAY, THEY
CAUGHT A 51-YEAR-OLD MAN
FROM HONDURAS, GUESS WHO HE
HAD WITH HIM AS A FAMILY?
A 6 MONTH OLD.
AND BECAUSE WORK AT HSI THEY
FOUND THAT TO BE COMPLETELY
FALSE.
THAT'S THE KIND OF STUFF WE
ARE DOING AND WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO DO.
>> Tucker: WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
IF WE GOT RID OF ICE?
>> EXACTLY.
RIGHT NOW, ICE, ON THE ERO
SIDE.
THIS YEAR SO FAR JUST THE
FIRST QUARTER, 66,000
INDIVIDUALS HAVE BEEN
DEPORTED.
OF THE ARRESTS THAT THEY
HAVE MADE 65 PERCENT OF
THOSE ARRESTS WERE ACTUALLY
PEOPLE WITH ADDITIONAL
CRIMINAL CONVICTIONS.
90% OF THOSE EITHER HAVE A
CRIMINAL CONVICTION OR A
PENDING CHARGE.
YOU GET RID OF ICE, THINK
ABOUT THAT.
SO, 66,000 NOT DEPORTED.
YOU HAVE JUST AN INCREDIBLE
AMOUNT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
DOING BAD THINGS BUT REMAIN
IN THE UNITED STATES.
ON THE HSI COMPONENT.
LAST YEAR ALONE, 34,000
ARRESTS, TUCKER.
34,000 CRIMINAL ARRESTS.
4,000, 5,000 GAINED.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING CASES.
CHILD EXPLOITATION CASES.
1.2 BILLION IN CURRENCY THEY
SEIZED.
THE LIST GOES ON AND ON AND
ON.
WHETHER YOU HAVE SOMEBODY
THAT PUTS OUT THE RECKLESS,
IRRESPONSE SICK RHETORIC
ABOUT ICE BEING ABOLISHED
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN.
THIS COUNTRY WILL ABSOLUTELY
BE LESS SAFE BECAUSE OF
THAT.
>> Tucker: IT'S DEMENTED.
NEVER ANY POPULAR SUPPORT
FOR IT.
NO POLL THAT SAYS GET RID OF
THE FBI WHILE WE ARE AT IT.
IF CONGRESS IN A DREAM WORLD
WERE WILLING TO HELP YOU.
DEMOCRATS WERE ON THE PAGE
IN PROTECTING AMERICA'S
BORDERS.
WHAT'S THE FIRST THING YOU
WOULD ASK THEM FOR.
>> TWO THINGS THEY HAVE TO
ADDRESS THE LEGAL FRAMEWORK.
THEY HAVE TO FIX THE FLORES
SETTLEZMENT AGREEMENT WHICH
MANDATES YOU CAN'T HOLD A
FAMILY MORE THAN 20 DAYS AND
THE CHILD TRAFFICKING
PROTECTION ACT THAT SAYS IF
YOU ARE FROM MEXICO OR
CANADA, WE GET TO SEND YOU
BACK.
BUT IF YOU ARE FROM THE
NORTHERN TRIANGLE COUNTRIES
WE CAN'T.
THOSE TWO THINGS EQUAL CATCH
AND RELEASE.
CONGRESS CAN FIX THOSE TWO
THINGS IN 15 MINUTES.
SECOND THING IS THEY
ABSOLUTELY NEED TO CONTINUE
THE FUNDING FOR ICE.
SPECIFICALLY ON THE
DETENTION BED SPACE.
IT'S JUST COMMON -- IT'S
COMMON SENSE, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: THEY DON'T CARE.
BUT YOU DO CARE.
AND I DON'T KNOW A SINGLE